people living in the rebel-held province
of ad lib face a perhaps impossible
dilemma stay in your home with the risk
it could be flattened at any time by an
airstrike or run into open country with
no shelter food or sanitation it would
be miraculous if anyone who decided to
stay here survive this bombing nowhere
is safe Syria's russian-backed military
has stepped up its efforts to take it
Lib according to people living there and
groups monitoring the conflict the man
with this phone is saying his final
prayers Meriton amin is to the south of
it lip city it sits next to a highway
the regime wants to control as it
advances on it Lib there is always hope
that someone will have survived beneath
the rubble but all the rescue workers
keep finding our bodies children's
bodies there will be no miracles tonight
a Syrian government forces
step up the pressure on ed Lib a million
people have now fled their homes
according to the UN and many of them are
heading north towards the turkey-syria
border Turkey's president calls that a
humanitarian disaster and a threat to
his country's national security Bernhard
Smith al-jazeera Antakya